what's going on everybody welcome to
another Q&A this Q&A is a little bit
more in entrepreneurship someone finance
and some about support from basically
friends family and so on so I've got a
lot of questions on things like how you
know how much money do you make - you
know how is basically your family
supported you throughout you know your
your entrepreneurship and then questions
on other things about finance to just
you know investing and stuff like that
so I'm just going to answer all those in
this video because I think they're all
pretty much related so just start like I
told you before I mean I've been
entrepreneurs I've been an entrepreneur
since I was about 12 years old but I
didn't actually like really start I mean
I was making a lot of money when I was
12 years old for what I was doing but I
never really made
I don't like try to make a business so
much out of it like I didn't really plan
I didn't really structure it like a
business that kind of stuff right and it
wasn't really until I was in college
that I actually really tried to really
came to the realization that I think I
could do this for a living like make
money online for a living it wasn't
really until college that I thought
about that and was like I think I'm
actually going to take a swing at this
like when I went to college I thought I
was going to get a real job right as
they say so but anyway you know I really
got started in college and at this time
I actually had a girlfriend and so
somebody somebody asked me if I if I
have a girlfriend right now
no I don't and if I did my wife would
kill me anyway my girlfriend at a time
now my wife was extremely supportive so
someone was asking basically you know
how does my wife kind of handle the
Entrepreneurship stuff and I mean she's
just hard percent supportive all of the
time there was never a time where she
doubted me even when I was doing kind of
which app would appear to most people to
be wild so for example one time I traded
my motorcycle sport bike nice great fun
motorcycle for 600 pounds of Lego but
before I did it I told her I said hey
I'm gonna
trade my motorcycle for all this Lego
and I'm just going to sell the Lego like
I'm not going to keep it I'm gonna sell
it and I'm gonna make a lot of profit
dude and you know I explained it to her
and her reaction was just like you know
okay
sounds like you've thought it through
you know and that's just been the story
the whole time and and that's why she's
my wife so so so yeah I mean it it helps
to have some sort of support when you're
trying to start your own and run your
own businesses or really do anything
that most people would perceive as risky
because most people are going to doubt
you I mean you're going to have you know
friends that support you and stuff but
for the most part most people will think
what you're doing is stupid crazy or
just isn't going to work or isn't a real
job all right so so having some sort of
support really does help and I think
that's probably all I'm going to really
say on that but I will say now getting
kind of into finance you know starting a
business is not something that you're
going to make a lot of money at
especially like you know someone asked
me how much money I make I'm really not
going to disclose that that would take a
really long time I have at least ten
income streams if not more so first of
all there's that also my income is
relatively volatile I mean over the
course of a year you can I can kind of
predict it out but it's pretty volatile
but I can say at least it goes up over
time my income at the moment goes up
about six to seven percent compounded
every single month that's insane
so when some people ask me like why I
don't take a job at like some Silicon
Valley company if you were to if you
first of all they can't give you that
much excitement right where all of my
energy all of my work goes into my own
equity I own 100% equity in my own
companies so all the energy and all the
work that I put into my companies I get
rewarded not immediately but almost
immediately like really quickly and it
and it only keeps building
top of that overtime like it just keeps
building up if you go to work for an
established company on like Facebook or
Apple or something you know they might
give you equity right they almost
certainly will but it's going to be a
tiny amount of equity and those
companies are you know they're not super
mature but they're not growing that much
compared to what they used to do right
when it was truly exciting and so they
came out for me that also if you were to
take my living income like I guess like
basically my income minus my expenses
right now I'm making pretty much the
same I would make if I went to go work
for like Google Apple Facebook you know
they're gonna pay you about six figures
probably like 120 to 150 starting on or
50,000 that is a year mmm
but then you have to factor in the cost
of living in a place like San Francisco
which is just absurd where rent is you
know three to five thousand dollars a
month it's just insane that's just rent
okay so so yeah so it you got to kind of
like think of those things but initially
starting out another reason why I'm not
going to break down exactly what I make
right now because what I make right now
is the the fruits of my labor from years
ago so if you were to take basically all
of the time I've put just into any one
of my businesses but let's just take the
YouTube channel in Python program in
that net if you took how much money I've
currently made today and divided it by
the number of hours that I've put into
it
you'd probably you'd find it's less than
minimum wage it's just less but if you
take maybe the amount of hours I've put
in in the last six months and the amount
of money I've made it's above minimum
wage now like I have worked and I've got
myself to the point where now yes I I'm
I'm making more of the minimum wage but
that's the result of a lot of work up to
this point but that's also just further
prove my point that it's very rewarding
when you're rewarded for the effort that
you put in you're getting it all back to
yourself rather than giving it to some
company but that's not to say I wouldn't
go work for some Silicon Valley company
so some people just are like I would
never go work for Microsoft or name some
other company that's not really how I
feel I just feel like it's unlikely for
one of those companies to be able to
offer me something that's is enticing as
what I do today I wake up I get to focus
on exactly what I want do exactly what I
want I get a lot of reward both in terms
of yes the equity return but also my
support from the community the people
that my viewers the people like you
that's extremely rewarding to me and so
for a company I just don't know that
anybody will ever be able to offer me
something
basically the supply will never probably
meet the demand right I demand a very
rewarding job and it's likely that these
companies just don't see me valuable
enough to give me the kind of job I
would require so I just probably won't
but that's that's that now on to
finances so you know there were times in
my life where I was basically 1 to 2
weeks away from having no more money
just being broke and luckily that's not
the case anymore but it used to be but
once you get out of that you start
having some money and you can put that
money somewhere and for me I save that
money and I put it usually for the most
part in like the stock market now I used
to trade but I found that you know
basically when you trade you have to
consider what would be how much money
would I you have to consider not how
much you made total you have to consider
how much money you made compared to how
much money you would have made if you
just bought and held right so for me
I actually beat the market but after
assuming I had just bought and hold and
then I bought and held and then done
business stuff I would have probably
made more money than I did when I would
trade it so for me it just makes more
sense after trying it and experiencing
it for myself that I'm just better off
running my own businesses and then
investing in the stock market it's just
like buying and holding because the
other thing you have to think about too
is like for example I buy for the most
part I do on some singular companies but
for the most part I just buy the S&P 500
ETF exchange-traded fund
and when you do that you not only get
the market return but you also get
dividends and so for example let's take
an average market return 6% a year then
if you if you take that but then you
also include dividends well dividends
are about a half a percent every quarter
so now you made an extra 2% over the
market two percent out of six percent
that's 33% more all right
that's huge right you beat the market by
33 percent if you just buy and hold and
collect dividends on top right so that's
a big deal mmm so for me that's just
what I've personally found it's better
for me to take my time you know I'm just
better at doing business than I am
trading I'm okay at trading I can beat
the market trading but it just makes
more fiscal sense to me to just buy and
hold take the market returns plus the
dividends plus all the money I make
working on businesses rather than
spending that time that I would be doing
curating a business trading so anyways
those are just my thoughts on
entrepreneurship Sport and finances if
you've got more questions on the topic
for free leaving below if you have other
questions you'd like me to answer leave
them below otherwise I'll see you in
another video